[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public tous les
soirs 18h 22h sur Public Sénat votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débats de
reportage et d'analyse on donne du temps
vous le savez à nos experts pour mieux
comprendre l'actualité et les crises que
nous traversons et voici le sommaire de
ce 28 novembre faut-il craindre la
Neuvième Vague de covid où la snober
après bientôt trois années d'épidémie
nombreuses sont les Français par
indifférence lassitude ou manque
d'informations qui ont laissé tomber
vaccination et gestes barrières pourtant
c'est le moment de remettre les masques
dans les transports
il faudrait que les le gouvernement de
la possibilité aux maires de pouvoir
instaurer le port du masque dans les
transports en commun en fonction des
spécialités du territoire et les
horaires
masque nouveau variant campagne de
vaccination réintégration des soignants
en non vaccinés on vous dit tout sur la
9e vague de covid juste après ces titres
et puis tout à l'heure pour notre second
débat vous le savez volontairement
décalé de l'actualité du jour on plonge
dans le monde virtuel décrypto monnaie
après la faillite de FTX la deuxième
plateforme mondiale d'échange la
confiance était le rompue dans 45
minutes on vous explique d'abord ce
qu'est une crypto-monnaie on se demande
si c'est possible de mieux les encadrer
et puis si elles peuvent ou non
s'imposer dans notre quotidien mais
d'abord le point sur les contaminations
en France avec Flora sauvage après la
calmie les voyants repassent au rouge
avec un taux d'incidence de 400K pour
100000 habitants un chiffre en
augmentation de 34% par rapport à la
semaine dernière et un taux de
reproduction de plus de 1 l'épidémie de
covid-19 repart à la hausse dans cet
officine parisienne la campagne de
vaccination pour la cinquième dose de
rappel a du mal à attirer les clients
on arrivera peut-être à cette suite et
chaque année il faudra une robe
vaccination il y a une certaine
lassitude des vaccins se sont un petit
peu plus protégés en disant qu'ils évite
les grosses crises de covid mais la
confiance se tend à diminué ça vous fera
deux euros 50 madame dans un contexte
tendu pour le système de santé avec
l'épidémie de grippe saisonnière et de
bronchiolite l'exécutif alerte sur la
reprise de circulation du virus et la
nécessité de se faire vacciner nous
sommes par rapport aux vagues de
vaccination précédente en dessous à peu
près 10 15% des personnes cibles
seulement vaccinées il faut absolument
accélérer cette vaccination accélérer la
vaccination contre le covid accélérer la
vaccination contre la grippe si il est
difficile d'estimer l'impact de la
Neuvième Vague trois ans après
l'apparition du covid-19 la couverture
vaccinale des personnes à risque est
nettement insuffisante selon santé
publique France
une Neuvième Vague et alors c'est le
titre volontairement un peu provocateur
mais aussi très représentatif d'une
partie des Français de leur perception
et pour détailler les enjeux de cette 9e
vague j'accueille Christine russeau
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes professeur
de virologie à l'Université Paris
Descartes et membre de l'Académie de
médecine Frédéric Valtou bonsoir
bienvenue député horizon de la
Seine-et-Marne mère de Fontainebleau
ancien président de la Fédération
hospitalière de France Gérald kierzeg
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi médecin
urgentiste chroniqueur santé directeur
médical de Doctissimo et votre livre
votre santé dans le monde d'après
préparer là aujourd'hui et publié aux
éditions du Rocher Mathieu croissanto
victori-spolitique est à mes côtés comme
tous les lundis et mercredi bonsoir
Mathieu bienvenue
volontairement provocateur je le dis
Christine mauzu on va faire passer à un
certain nombre de messages de prévention
déjà on peut clairement parler de
Neuvième Vague on y est notamment on y
est on est en pleine ascension tout
monte tous les indicateurs montent les
incidence le nombre de positifs qui est
en plus tout à fait sous-estimé puisque
les gens se font pas beaucoup tester
dans la mesure où là aussi l'habitude de
ce test antigénique un petit peu perdu
et puis les symptômes sont quand même
modestes et quand on a un petit rhume on
pense pas que ça peut être le covid donc
il y a une vraie sous-estimation plus la
grève de des labos tout ça fait que on
n'a pas envie de déclarer qu'on est
positif et de de pas pouvoir emmener les
enfants à l'école donc tous ces
conditions sont favorables à ce que ça
ça bouge et en plus ça bouge à cause
d'un les chiffres bougent ils sont tous
en augmentation à cause du nouveau virus
on est avec le variant bq1 qui est
invariant un sous variant de soulignage
de de bs5
c'est la grande famille au micro qui
domine le monde actuellement le monde
entier est infecté par des variants au
micro et celui là alors plusieurs études
montrent que il a une capacité déjà
échappé à l'immunité ancienne à
l'immunité antibuable bien sûr il a une
bonne capacité à pénétrer dans les
cellules par contre on n'a pas assez de
recul sur sur
l'induction de femmes clinique grave
mais à l'évidence
a priori pour le moment on a
l'impression que il n'en donne pas plus
que que les autres si ce n'est que il se
répand vraiment très facilement alors ça
c'est évidemment un enjeu majeur il y a
toutes les conditions actuelles qui font
que il fait froid etc bien sûr on y
reviendra en détail sur tous ces
éléments Frédéric Valtou je disais dans
dans mon sommaire dans mes titres
indifférence lassitude manque
d'information il y a tout ça dans le
cocktail de de l'opinion publique de la
de la société française en ce moment
face à cette 9e vague alors lassitude
incompréhension je sais pas bien c'est
vrai qu'il y a une forme de banalisation
de maintenant des pics des vagues
il y a aussi peut-être l'incompréhension
vis-à-vis des vaccins du rythme de
vaccination
où est-ce qu'on en est des publics
fragiles des la nécessité de se faire
vacciner aussi peut-être pour des
publics moins fragiles et plus éloignés
du risque voilà c'est peut-être ça dans
l'esprit de des Français en tout cas ce
qu'il faut quand même avoir en ligne de
mire
c'est que pour toute vague et surtout
une vague qui arrive en hiver et donc à
un moment où il y a pas que le covid qui
aujourd'hui fait pression sur les
hospitalière c'est la situation de de
l'hôpital des soignants je rappelle que
jusqu'à présent 85% des patients
qui ont dû être qui ont été pris en
charge dans un établissement long était
à l'hôpital des patients covid touchés
par des covid aux formes j'ai dire
graves ont été pris en charge à
l'hôpital donc c'est vraiment l'hôpital
qui a été plus que d'autres en première
ligne du covid si il y a une
mobilisation un peu plus forte là dans
les prochaines semaines autour du covid
alors qu'il y a la bronchiolite qu'on
annonce une vague de grille un peu
difficile que l'hôpital va pas mieux
qu'il allait qu'il ne l'était il y a
trois ans voilà il faut aussi penser à
la capacité des Hospitaliers de faire
face on va détailler évidemment on va en
reparler dans un court instant mais je
voudrais vous entendre kazak sur
peut-être les la comparaison alors c'est
aussi une question évidemment pour
Christine Rosie ou mais on est quand
même loin des du niveau de contamination
du mois de janvier de de cette année
janvier 2022 on n'a pas encore assez sur
tous même s'il y a une sous-estimation
sûrement les labos sont en grève on se
teste moins vous nous l'avez dit ce qui
est capital c'est de voir la virulence
de de micro-ondes et depuis qu'on a au
micro on a quand même une capacité de
immunitaire de la population liée au
vaccin lié à nos capacités immunitaires
naturelles de résister et ce virus
envoie-moi à l'hôpital et c'est ça qui
est assez fondamental Christine le
disait à l'instant c'est des gens qui ne
vont pas réanimation quand on regarde
les chiffres il y a 1000 patients qui
sont en soins critiques je parle pas de
réanimation je parle de soins critiques
c'est-à-dire sur un total de 20 000
litres donc on voit bien qu'on est sur
des niveaux totalement acceptables et
c'est pour ça que moi depuis des mois je
dis il faut qu'on arrête de parler de
vagues parce que vague c'est très
anxiogène et les vagues la première et
la deuxième vague c'était des vagues de
saturation hospitalière et je crois que
c'est important de bien faire le
distinguo la saturation hospitalière ce
n'est plus le cas ou en tout cas c'est
comme d'habitude j'allais dire
malheureusement et là je rejoins
totalement freine avec valtrous
c'est-à-dire que on est à un niveau de
l'hôpital où on est en permanence des
services de réanimation des services
d'urgence des lits de médecine aussi qui
sont saturées et c'est ça qui est très
compliqué et le covid va se rajouter
même si
de variant au micro-ondes c'est pas
celui qui va envoyer le plus de monde à
l'hôpital mais la grille plus au micro
en plus plus ça fait que
structurellement on a un hôpital qui est
déjà à la peine et qui va être encore
plus comme tous les hivers Mathieu
plutôt qu'une forme de lassitude je
pense qu'il y a une forme de confusion
chez les Français parce que d'abord le
virus a changé parce que vous venez de
dire donc c'est pas le même virus qui a
2 ans et on a parfois du mal à imaginer
que voilà il est peut-être moins
dangereux mais il faut quand même s'en
protéger parce que les critères ont
changé souvenez-vous il y a deux ans le
président de la République en octobre
2020 il déclenche un confinement en
disant l'objectif c'est de revenir à
5000 contaminations par jour aujourd'hui
on a quand même contaminations par jour
50000 peut-être c'est ce qu'on dit
personne ne parle de confinement donc
les mesures ont changé aussi parce que
les virus ont changé et parce que la
population s'est protégé aussi avec les
vaccins mais l'usage des masques est-ce
qu'il est utile pas utile ça n'est plus
très clair dans la tête des Français le
vaccin est-ce qu'il protège oui des
formes graves est-ce qu'il empêche de
contaminer non mais regardez il y a eu
un débat ressembler la semaine dernière
sur est-ce qu'il faut renvoyer des
soignants au vaccinés à l'hôpital sans
critères épidémiologiques j'allais dire
juste sur le critère social de comment
on fait pour ces soignants qu'on puisse
salaire bref je pense qu'il y a une
grande confusion et ça mériterait un
message de clarté alors peut-être un
message différent de celui d'à 2 ans et
celui d'un an parce que les
circonstances et le virus sont
différents mais un message assez clair
et fort de la part des autorités
sanitaires je focus sur le l'état de
notre système hospitalier face à ce
virus alors je vais continuer de parler
de Neuvième Vague excusez-moi parce que
c'est une peut-être une possibilité
ça dit bien ce qui est cette épidémie on
a on est vraiment une montée d'un nombre
de virus positif réel quoi on a vraiment
un pic qui est en train de se dessiner
donc faut pas il faut appeler un chat
chat comme tous les virus respiratoires
il y a des flux et refus il y a des
vagues non mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que le côté vague est très
anxiogène la première et deuxième vague
on n'est pas suffisamment anxiété
française
l'épidémie se dessine des vagues alors
après on dit bah finalement cette vague
annoncée n'était qu'une vaguette tant
mieux mais ça reste une vague vaguelette
ça reste la même chose par contre ce qui
est illusoire c'est de vouloir éradiquer
le virus on a quand même tous les penché
on va pas pouvoir en Chine il y a
quelques mois là encore et ça entraîne
cette confusion et et au-delà de la
confusion le manque de confiance je
pense qu'il y a un vrai problème de
confiance nous on le voit avec les
patients j'ai quand on essaie de leur
proposer le vaccin etc il faut se battre
d'arguments en argument plus important
et je crois qu'un peu plus de clarté
notamment en disant bah voilà la
stratégie du tout vaccinal a changé on
est maintenant sur une stratégie
vaccinale ciblée je crois que ça serait
important de porter ce message
d'ailleurs la Haute Autorité de Santé la
clairement mis dans les recommandations
maintenant c'est les gens à risque qui
doivent être vaccinés et ça ça a changé
il faut qu'on porte ce message là alors
il y a l'état de l'hôpital et vous
l'avez évoqué l'un et l'autre je propose
d'entendre sur ce thème Bruno megarden
qui est chef du service réanimation de
l'hôpital Lariboisière de Paris le
problème évidemment cette fois-ci c'est
que cette vague covid va coïncider avec
la vague de la grippe et avec
probablement la vague des bronchiolites
chez l'enfant qui n'est toujours pas
terminé et donc de fait évidemment
l'hôpital est déjà en très grande
souffrance et on va avoir de très
grosses difficultés pour l'hiver qui
vient tout il est il est là le risque de
cette 9e vague il est là il est bien sûr
il est entré dans cette dans cet état de
l'hôpital français on a déjà fait
plusieurs débats sur ce plateau on va
pas y consacrer les 45 minutes mais
c'est quand même ça la vraie difficulté
du mot
vague de covid ou Pava covid la vie
continue les autres pathologies les
autres maladies sont là et que l'hôpital
est un niveau d'épuisement qui est fort
je parle de l'hôpital en tant que
structure en tant que organisation bien
sûr que les soignants eux aussi peuvent
être plus ou moins dans la fatigue dans
les mais l'hôpital en tant que
institution aujourd'hui est une
institution fragile fragilisée épuisée
et donc l'accumulation effectivement la
mer en danger inévitablement Jacques
quézek là dessus
la grippe le covid les virus
respiratoires ce sont des gens adultes
généralement fragiles âgés qui risquent
effectivement de saturer les services de
réanimation et on manque de l'hymne
réanimation en permanence quand on
regarde les rapports avant même le covid
les taux de saturation des services de
réanimation c'est de l'ordre de 100%
chaque année donc on voit bien que c'est
en flux tendu en permanence et ça on
paye une politique depuis 10 ou 15 ans
de réduction de fermeture de service de
proximité donc ça c'est grip et tous les
virus respiratoires et le covid et la
goutte d'eau qui fait déborder le vase
et puis il y a le problème de la
bronchelite ce sont des services
différents puisque pendant que lead ça
touche des enfants des nourrissons et là
sont les services d'urgence pédiatriques
et les services de réanimation
pédiatrique qui sont là aussi à l'os
c'est-à-dire qu'on a le même problème
mais ce sont deux types de services qui
sont qui sont différents services de
réanimation ça parle de capacité
hospitalières aujourd'hui à l'hôpital de
toute façon quand il y a une pression
sur un service on prend personnel
ailleurs pour le mettre sur notre
service mais on désorganise donc on voit
bien que c'est pas un sujet de de
bronchiolite pédiatrie covid en
réanimation c'est un problème de
capacité globale de l'hôpital
effectivement concentrer ses forces sur
la même système même si ce variant est
peut-être même vous avez dit on en est
pas encore sûr mais pour l'instant on se
dit on n'est pas saturation il y a pas
tant de personnes en réanimation
la situation de l'hôpital fait que cette
Neuvième Vague peut quand même amener
une saturation oui ou non Frédéric
bateau et ensuite moi je le pense donc
il faut peut-être organiser les choses
pour que la charge rappelait 85% des
patients qu'on assistait hospitalisation
l'ont été à l'hôpital et pas dans les
autres établissements peut-être qu'une
fois on pourra enfin essayer d'organiser
les choses de manière à ce que
toute l'offre de soins et je pense là à
nos amis des cliniques prennent aussi
leur part de de
prise en charge leur part de boulot et
finalement à un moment donné on va
laisser la possibilité je vous donne la
parole il faut mieux équilibrer les
choses le plus gros souci c'est
l'absence de vaccination de toute la
population cible de plus de 60 ans et
c'est celle-là qui va à l'hôpital quand
elle est malade qui a quand elle covid
donc le plus difficile pour le moment
c'est d'anticiper ce qui va se passer en
décembre voire au moment des fêtes et
donc là la prévention à l'évidence doit
être renforcée et c'est pas le tout de
communiquer et il faut aussi la
logistique pour cent de plus de 60 ans
selon santé publique France alors je
crois que le le message c'est surtout
c'est un nouveau vaccin on a le vaccin
qui correspond aux variants au micro 5
mais à 5 il faut vraiment le dire on est
dans une situation quand même très
correcte où on a le vaccin qui
correspond au virus qui circule on a
juste on devrait accélérer maintenant
cette vaccination dans cette population
qui risque d'aller à l'hôpital et c'est
vrai que là la mentalité et les et les
cas graves actuellement c'est quand même
encore à peine meilleur pour les plus de
80 ans on n'est pas on n'est pas au-delà
des 50 % par exemple pour les 80 ans
exactement
d'infections dans les EHPAD elles ont
pas été très graves on n'a pas eu besoin
de beaucoup d'hospitalisation mais
malgré que c'était l'été mais là on est
quand même il faut anticiper qu'on est
en train de préparer le mois de décembre
et et la période des fêtes et ça c'est
pas possible de laisser les papiers et
mamie aller à l'hôpital Mathieu hameau
et ensuite ça veut dire qu'il faut
rouvrir les vaccinodrome par exemple bah
il faut au moins augmenter les capacités
avoir plus incitatif auprès des médecins
généralistes j'ai encore des amis assez
âgés qui m'ont dit on m'a même pas
proposé la vaccination
c'est moi qui ai dû la réclamer je crois
que vraiment il faut inciter il faut
inciter les pharmaciens moi mon
pharmacien il est débordé il y a plus de
rendez-vous jusqu'à fin janvier donc ça
veut dire que il faut augmenter les
capacités en donnant des bras à droite à
gauche mais c'est vraiment ridicule de
pas vacciné maintenant et de pas
convaincre on a le vaccin qui correspond
au virus qui circule voilà non mais je
suis totalement d'accord il faut
anticiper c'est ce que vous disiez et
d'autant plus qu'on sait de manière
traditionnelle et j'arrête un siècle
c'est bien que les 15 derniers jours du
mois décembre sont toujours les jours
les plus conclus de les semaines les
plus compliquées pour les hôpitaux parce
que c'est là que la médecine de ville
évidemment pendant des vacances et c'est
bien logique et ralentit sa capacité
prise en charge et finalement l'hôpital
se retrouve tout seul à un moment où
effectivement on est au quasiment pic de
l'hiver on est à un moment où
effectivement la pression sur le système
de santé est très forte et donc c'est
pas le problème de l'embolie des
services de réanimation ça prennent de
l'embolie de l'hôpital en général des
urgences
qui fait qu'effectivement et puis les
hospitaliers ont partent aussi en
vacances et donc c'est vraiment un
moment où les l'hôpital est dans un état
critique donc si on peut pour une fois
anticiper sur la vaccination sur la
répartition des des forces pour la prise
en charge de cette période effectivement
on évitera des difficultés à l'hôpital
voir des accidents qu'on souhaite pas
mais qui peuvent arriver à ce moment-là
on a fait une titrer ce débat peut-on
sauver Noël et puis on n'a pas voulu
être inutilement non plus anxiogène mais
voyez c'est quand même une question
je crois que là pour le coup on n'est
plus dans ce débat là
on était dans une espèce d'anxiété
généralisée dire est-ce que on va
pouvoir passer passer Noël rappelez-vous
de cette formule célèbres et
malencontreuse papi mamie à la cuisine
en couple etc c'est le premier ministre
non
c'était Rémi Salomon était présent de la
commission médicale d'établissement de
la PHP qui avait dit ça c'est sûr
et je pense que le message commun tout
autour de cette table et que tous les
professionnels de santé partagent c'est
de dire les plus fragiles il faut les
vacciner et voir des taux de 30-36%,
c'est insuffisant chez les plus fragiles
j'entends votre argument mais on peut
peut-être quand même dire aux
téléspectateurs qui sont en train de
nous regarder
faites-vous tester faites-vous vacciner
faites un test avant d'aller en réunion
de famille pour Noël moi je ne pense pas
ça au stade de circulation en virage je
pense que encore une fois tester ou pas
tester ça change pas grand chose quand
on a des symptômes on s'isole et surtout
quand on est fragile on se fait vacciner
c'est ça le message pragmatique nous
dans les services d'urgence vous croyez
que les gens qui arrivent avec des
symptômes respiratoires on leur fait des
tests on leur fait pas des tests
systématiquement non non moi je suis pas
je suis désolé je suis pas beaucoup de
votre avis je trouve qu'au contraire il
faut dire que il faut se faire tester
dans la mesure où les symptômes modestes
comme un rhume les gens croient pas que
c'est le covid et que il faut faire
attention déjà dire à tous ceux qui ont
un rhume de mettre un masque c'est déjà
voilà c'est déjà très important c'est
comme au Japon ceux qui sont malades ils
protège les autres et je crois que
et puis il faut s'attendre que si la
Neuvième Vague continue à augmenter il
va falloir quand même inciter fortement
aux masques dans les transports et si
vous avez la grippe mettez un masque
aussi c'est ça le message même si votre
négatif et si vous avez des symptômes
mais c'est un autre virus respiratoire
mais la grippe mettez un masque quand
même et protéger les autres je suis 100%
d'accord avec avec vous avec cet
argument sauf que ferry Valtou on est on
sera en janvier à trois ans de de
d'épidémie les premiers cas c'était
recensés en France c'était voilà donc on
sera trois ans et moi je j'étais
persuadé parce que je suis un optimiste
de nature que bon bah nos comportements
allaient changer profondément et qu'on
aurait ce bon réflexe de se dire je suis
un peu malade j'ai un petit rhume je
mets un masque c'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui c'est un peu plus le cas
je veux dire vous allez dans des
commerces ça arrive que maintenant j'ai
beaucoup de commerçants porte le masque
dans les restaurants dans les pharmacies
tout le monde quasiment toutes les
pharmacien porte le porte le masque ce
qu'on voyait pas il y a avant le covid
donc je suis assez d'accord mais dans
les transports il faut une mesure
coercitive là maintenant là dans des
territoires qui sont peut-être plus
touchés que d'autres il faudrait pouvoir
donner la possibilité au préfet de
décréter le port du masque obligatoire
dans des réseaux de transport
métropolitain là où effectivement il y a
une concentration à un moment donné de
la du virus donc et puis cette fois-ci
on sait qu'on les a les masques donc
enfin j'espère je tiens pas le stock
mais je pense qu'on les a donc
raisonnablement
on devrait à nouveau aller proposer le
masque obligatoire dans les transports
là où les territoires sont touchés
sur les trois ans ça fait trois ans moi
j'aimerais bien qu'on ait des
évaluations des retours d'expérience sur
l'efficacité réelle des mesures qui ont
été prises parce qu'à chaque fois qu'il
y a une augmentation d'une allez je
reprends votre terme d'une vague de test
positives de gens qui ont des
contaminations on voit qu'il y a des
mesures qui sont prises différentes d'un
pays à l'autre on voit bien que l'Italie
l'Allemagne son comportés différemment
différemment chez nous également mais il
y a pas d'évaluation scientifique de
l'efficacité de tel ou telle mesure on a
un peu l'impression que quand les
chiffres augmentent il faut une mesure
qu'est-ce qu'on fait la mesure la plus
simple et la moins emmerdante pardon de
ce terme-là c'est de dire le masque
quelle est l'efficacité réelle je prends
l'exemple de l'Italie qui a gardé très
longtemps le masque obligatoire est-ce
qu'ils ont échappé aux vagues non ils
n'ont pas échappé aux vagues mais c'est
ce retour d'expérience qui sera je suis
pas médecin donc mais je pense que le
port du Mas c'est du bon sens à partir
du moment où il concentration on est
dans les transports et dans les
transports il y a concentration
on met le masque et même s'il y a qu'une
personne sur cinq sur dix qui est porte
du virus parfois même sur son apercevoir
ou son avoir les symptômes et bien au
moins on protège franchement le port du
masque il y a pas besoin de d'études
scientifiques pour penser que c'est du
bon sens de porter le masque enfin en
plus il y a eu les études scientifiques
qui le prouvaient un de toutes les
façons mais le virus les aérosols ça y
est c'est prouvé c'est fini il y a plus
de discussion sur le fait que du virus
il y en a plein les transmission
par voie aérienne le virus il flotte il
y en a plein de métro c'est une évidence
il faut pas il faut pas
être masque quand on est mais même il y
a beaucoup d'assymptomatiques on est on
a beaucoup de portage à
sainte-thématiques et il faut y penser
qu'il faudrait une mesure contraignante
de nouveau le masque obligatoire dans
les transports ou alors effectivement le
régionaliser comme dit Frédéric valtour
je pense que il faut le faire par région
parce qu'il y a effectivement
répartition de le taux d'incidence c'est
pas le même partout donc effectivement
il faut le voir plus la densité de métro
on voit bien à Paris les autobus s'il y
en a maintenant beaucoup moins et ils
sont bien plein donc il faut faire
attention tout ça est dans un
conditionnement de froid il faut aérer
les classes chez les enfants et puis et
puis les rhumes chez les enfants il y en
a plein les écoles et là il y a plus de
test donc faut quand même se dire que il
y a un grand masque non mais il y a un
vrai relâchement réel il y a un
relâchement qui se passe que on n'y
croit pas il va falloir attendre que la
vague monte pour ne pas décider moi je
pense que il faut bien expliquer que
dans un environnement quelqu'un qui se
sent à risque il faut absolument qu'il
porte le masque même s'il n'est pas
infecté alors ça c'est important parce
que pédagogiquement là aussi il faut
qu'on rappelle que le masque chirurgical
il protège de moins je je j'ai des
particules et si jamais ce masque
chirurgical je ne vais pas projeter ces
particules
je ne vais pas contaminer la personne en
face de moi en revanche les gens qui
sont dans les transports en commun avec
un mastergical pensant eux-mêmes être
protégé c'est pas le cas les gens
fragiles il faut qu'ils portent un
masque FFP2 c'est ce fameux masque
canard qu'il a à une efficacité
importante d'être contaminée de
particules en suspension juste sur les
enfants en médecine à chaque fois qu'on
prescrit quelque chose et le masque ça
pourrait être une prescription c'est
bénéfices risques or le bénéfice bon
peut-être compris quand on est malade
bien sûr de le porter mais le risque de
se masque là ils sont importants s'il
risque à le risque psychologique les
enfants ont parlé des classes est-ce
qu'on va remettre les masques
obligatoires dans les classes je pense
que personne enfin en terme
d'acceptabilité sociale en termes de
soutenabilité je pense que c'est plus
possible tant qu'on a pas de
démonstration d'une circulation virale
importante dans les classes il y a pas
de justification il faut quand même
avoir des réponses face aux résultats
réels de ce qui se passe mais en fait le
débat pardon je vais vous laisser la
parole tout de suite ce qui est ce qui
est intéressant dans votre débat c'est
est-ce que finalement on entre
guillemets on s'habitue à vivre avec ce
virus sans mesure coercitives
devient plus dangereux il faut remettre
un un coup d'interdiction et ouvrir des
vaccinosaureaux mais cetera et cetera on
serait dans une stratégie à la chinoise
effectivement on préconiserait le retour
du masque même chez les enfants on
serait voilà mais on en est pas là on
est effectivement dans l'idée de pouvoir
vivre avec et donc finalement de limiter
d'écraser les pics on va dire ou
d'écraser le sommet des vagues de
manière à ce qu'effectivement soit
surligne hospitalière soit par rapport
aux problèmes de santé publique en
général que ça représente on puisse
effectivement ce cohabiter avec le avec
le le virus donc il s'agit pas non plus
de faire peur à tout le monde mais là où
on sait qu'il y a concentration est des
territoires particulièrement touchés et
ben je pense que le prix du masque c'est
vraiment le minimum je reviens sur ce
que disait Mathieu croissant de tout à
l'heure finalement les les critères ils
sont ils sont mouvants en fonction de
l'état de l'opinion et il y a il y a
quand même une question de
responsabilité
gouvernementale est-ce que il manque une
grande campagne de de communication et
de vaccination est-ce qu'il manque de
moyens pour mieux vacciner Frédéric
valtry il y a des campagnes qui ont été
faites hein
peut-être qu'il faut sonner plus fort la
mobilisation comme vous le disiez de des
professionnels de santé pour les inciter
là encore à promouvoir et à faciliter
l'accès au vaccin il y a sans doute
effectivement les les professionnels il
y a sans doute la communication il y a
peut-être en parler plus dans les médias
parce que c'est vrai que là aussi ce
soir je suis content qu'on en parle mais
regardez le nom des missions aujourd'hui
qu'on consacre à ces sujets là elles
sont beaucoup moins que quelques temps
on a le sentiment de se répéter donc
c'est cette histoire et donc un problème
revient j'entends cet argument et on
essaie de faire de la pédagogie sur ce
plateau et on continuera de le faire
mais mais ça rejoint
de faire la quatrième dose quoi le
rappel j'ai cette tort voilà ça c'est
pas encore décidé l'achat S n'a pas
encore décidé ça me préoccupe parce que
je trouve que
la Haute Autorité de Santé n'a pas
encore décidé et c'est vrai que à partir
du moment où on veut faire de la
prévention et arrêter la circulation du
virus c'est maintenant qu'il faut le
faire et il faut le faire il faut le
faire plus là les campagnes de
vaccination mais en fait la situation
est telle que déjà ceux qui devrait être
vacciner ne sont pas donc il faut et il
y a pas la logistique pour vacciner tout
le monde donc il faut quand même laisser
la place pour vacciner ce en ont besoin
c'est plus le problème
je sais pas si il y a le il y a pas le
fait unique du nombre de vaccins il y a
la logistique encore une fois c'est la
logistique qui est qui est qui est plus
compliqué alors les
du travail qui avait fait qui avait fait
les pompiers lors des précédents de
campagne de vaccination
ils ont le test streptocoque ils ont
vaccination qui grippal ils ont la ils
ont quand même beaucoup de prévention à
faire donc c'est vrai que pour le moment
ils accumulent hein mais ils sont
partants dans ce qu'on va tuer rigoles
parce que les pompiers je mets toujours
les pompiers sur le devant de la scène
parce que je les connais bien et je sais
à quel point ils peuvent être efficaces
dans le cadre d'une campagne de
vaccination dans ce contexte de tension
hospitalière dans ton parler il y a une
question qui revient vous venez de
l'évoquer très rapidement sur le devant
de la scène c'est celle de la
réintégration ou non des soignants non
vaccinés en écoute pour lancer cette
partie du débat le porte-parole du
gouvernement Olivier Véran
Haute Autorité de santé qui est une
autorité indépendante et heureusement
continue d'écrire que il n'y a pas lieu
de réintégrer les soignants pour
plusieurs raisons et que si elle devait
produire une recommandation différente
on serait probablement amené à l'écouter
à la suivre ce qu'on a absolument
toujours fait et j'accueille tout de
suite Steve Jourdain sur ce plateau
bonsoir Steve bienvenue dans ce contexte
il y a certains parlementaires qui
poussent effectivement à cette
réintégration des des soignants on parle
de non vaccinants on parle de combien de
personnes ici d'avoir un chiffre très
précis commençons par rappeler que
l'obligation vaccinale a été votée a été
2021 l'exécutif parler à l'époque on
s'en souvient d'environ 15000 personnels
soignants et non soignants concernés par
la mesure aujourd'hui on en est très
loin la Fédération Hospitalière estime
qu'il y a 4000 professionnels de environ
500 infirmiers qui sont actuellement
suspendus selon le gouvernement il y
aurait également 75 médecins et
pharmaciens suspendus sur les 85 000 en
exercice dans les EHPAD on parlerait de
100 infirmiers tout au plus alors il y a
une proposition conditions de loi qui a
été déposée par la France insoumise qui
demande cette réintégration pour pallier
les pénuries d'effectifs qui est pour le
texte n'a pas été adopté mais le débat
qui a eu jeudi dernier à enflammer
l'Assemblée nationale écoutez
d'avoir pu trouver une petite messe
quierie obscoutive pour ne pas laisser
une niche aller jusqu'au bout
tu vas la fermer
[Applaudissements]
veur le député centriste Olivier Servat
qui est sous le coup d'une sanction
disciplinaire à la suite de cette sortie
alors sur le fond du texte on va voir
les groupes qui ont voté pour et ceux
qui ont voté contre le RN a dit oui on
se souvient que Marine Le Pen en avait
fait une promesse de campagne tous les
députés présents se sont prononcés en
faveur de la réintégration des soignants
à l'exception d'une députée chez les LR
on est également en faveur de la
réintégration des soignants l'ensemble
du groupe a voté pour à l'exception du
député médecin Philippe Juvin à la
France insoumise pas de surprise le
texte émane de Laurence est un grand oui
en revanche dans la majorité
présidentielle la réintégration pas
question le goût prenait sens à voter
contre tout comme la majorité du groupe
modem et du groupe horizon quelques
heures plus tard Emmanuel Macron a fait
le service après-vente écoutez il faut
que la décision soit scientifiquement
établie si les scientifiques aujourd'hui
et les médecins et les soignants nous
disent
c'est souhaitable d'un point de vue
scientifique de réintégrer ces soignants
il faut que le gouvernement de fasse ça
n'est pas un choix politique une
décision scientifique qui pourrait
intervenir dans les prochaines semaines
Thomas en deux avis vont être rendus au
gouvernement début janvier l'un émane de
la Haute Autorité de Santé l'autre du
Comité consultatif national d'éthique je
termine en précisant qu'au Sénat aussi
la question pourrait revenir dans les
débats puisque certains sénateurs LR
comme Sylviane Noël demande à ce qu'une
proposition de loi sur la réintégration
des soignants soit inscrites à l'ordre
du jour pour l'instant ces élus sont
extrêmement minoritaires ici au Sénat
merci Steve pour toutes ces informations
Gérald kirzet qu'est-ce qu'il faut
réintégrer ses soignants non vaccinés
moi je pense que oui il faut les
réintégrer parce que on a démontré que
le vaccin était efficace
individuellement pour se prémunir d'une
forme grave mais qu'il n'empêchait pas
la transmission la contamination or
l'argument principal pour exclure ses
soignants c'était de dire vous mettez en
danger vos patients c'était ça le
rationnel scientifique initial ce
rationnel scientifique initial il n'est
plus valable aujourd'hui parce que les
choses en avance en marchant et on a
compris que ce vaccin n'empêchait pas la
transmission donc il y a plus de raison
scientifique la deuxième raison c'est
que je pense qu'il faut de l'apaisement
moi quand j'entends ces débats à
l'Assemblée nationale quand je vois
qu'on manque de bras à l'hôpital alors
évidemment ça va en rien régler le
problème de la crise structurelle du
manque de personnel etc et c'est mentir
que de dire que ça va régler le problème
en revanche tous les bras tous les
volontaires sont importants et je pense
que oui il faut réintégrer pour apaiser
le climat et pour donner un signe
d'ouverture à ces soignant là et
attention tous ces soignants ne sont pas
antivaxes évidemment les antivax n'ont
rien à faire dans le système de santé un
anti-vax n'est pas dans le système de
santé pourquoi parce que quand on est
profit à part d'un soignant c'est quand
même une démarche un peu particulière de
reculer qu'à titre individuel sa balance
bénéficie ce qui était pas favorable il
y a sûrement des antivax et c'est
sûrement pas des gens que je vais
défendre en revanche je pense qu'en 2022
novembre 2022 ce qu'on connaît de ce
vaccin qui protège individuellement et
qui protège pas du risque de
transmission on peut pas dire quand un
soignant qui serait réintégré
en danger ces patients Christine vous eu
que dit l'Académie de médecine je
rappelle que vous en êtes membre sur sur
cette hypothèse réintégration non elle
dit non elle dit non elle dit non elle
dit fermement non et elle dit non avec
le fait que c'est incompatible avec le
métier lui-même ça n'a pas beaucoup de
sens alors les arguments sont assez
nombreux alors concernant la
transmission il faut pas jouer avec les
mots c'est évident que la vaccination
diminue le risque de transmission c'est
pas parce qu'il en reste un peu qu'il
faut pas vacciner et je pense qu'il faut
maintenant d'ailleurs on a bien vu au
cours du temps que au début c'était une
angoisse une peur de vaccin mais
maintenant le nombre de personnes
concernées il y a plus qu'à essayer de
les convaincre qu'on efface qui sont
face à un nouveau risque le covidon
c'est intéressant pour personne prendre
des risques pour soi-même et pour les
patients c'est pas bien faire rentrer le
virus dans l'hôpital ça n'a pas
d'intérêt et donc franchement c'est
vacciné ou pas fait rentrer à l'hôpital
l'autre chose c'est transmission ou non
oui non
actuellement en poste même si on a une
aux trois doses on a plus le schéma
vaccinal qui protège de toute façon dès
qu'il faut bien voir que à date le
personnel hospitalier n'est plus protégé
puisque il y a pas eu les rappels et
bien justement oui excusez-moi mais les
rappels la chas recommande de faire les
rappels chez les soignants donc
recommandation pas obligation on est sur
un débat oui enfin sur l'obligation ou
pas et sur la réintégration oui mais
c'est c'est vous nous dites bien quand
on est vacciné on transmet moins le
virus on transmet moins parce que le
virus se multiplie moins et se multiplie
moins dans la sphère ORL et surtout il
se multiplie moins dans les poumons donc
la durée d'expression du virus est
beaucoup plus courte et la risque de
transmission et et léger et en plus les
soignants portent le masque donc
excusez-moi mais je pense que la bonne
mesure univers tout ça tout ça fait que
c'est vrai qu'en plus il faut renforcer
le message les soignants doivent se
faire vacciner avec le vaccin actuel qui
est bivalent qui est contre le micros 5
il faut les protéger il faut qu'ils
protège les patients que ce soit un
service de cardiologie d'ailleurs de
greffe rénale ou de pédiatrie il y a il
y a pas il faut empêcher la circulation
du virus dans l'hôpital
sur la question du climat social est-ce
que réintégrer je rappelle que vous
étiez il y a encore quelques semaines
près de la Fédération Hospitalière
est-ce que réintégrer les soignants non
vaccinés c'est forcément un apaisement
ou est-ce que au contraire ça peut être
mal vécu par ceux qui sont fait vacciner
comment vous vous le ressentez ça peut
être très mal vécu par ce qui se sont
fait vacciner et quand on va dans les
hôpitaux et qu'on pose la question
eux-mêmes ne souhaitent pas la
réintégration de ceux qui étaient leurs
collègues qui sont totalement marginaux
parce qu'ils le disent totalement
marginaux mais qui effectivement pour
des raisons pas toujours scientifiques
sont des gens qui ont voulu se mettre en
marge effectivement d'une obligation et
quand on est soignant ce grande
obligation on les accepte et si on ne
les accepte pas et ben effectivement on
se met en marge comme vous le dit très
bien et comme l'Académie de médecine le
dit depuis le début effectivement en
marge en marge du système et quand on
les interroge ils veulent pas la
réintégration des de ceux qui ne sont
pas vaccinés ce serait un très mauvais
signal vis-à-vis de tous ceux qui se
sont pliés à à ce vaccin à cette
obligation là je le rappelle je le dis
je le dis depuis plus d'un an quand on
est soignant on a de toute façon
couverture vaccinale qui est bien plus
large que vous et moi et qu'à partir de
là voilà on ne fait pas des chinoiseries
autour de tel ou tel vaccin le dire
voilà on rentre complètement oui c'est
le cas de le dire on rentre complètement
dans dans le système et en plus on
saigne on sait pas on sait on sait que
on est sur des car ils sont totalement
marginaux on est sur quelques unités
0,3% de des soignants
ça dépend de ça franchement si c'est 03
c'est 0,5 enfin
moi je ne dis pas que des collègues
soignants c'est rien
première chose qui fera que l'hôpital
sera sauvé mais c'est comme ça qu'on
nous présente les choses il faut
réintégrer parce que on est d'accord
c'est pas ça qui va sauver l'hôpital et
c'est pas ça qui est la crise de
l'hôpital en revanche de dire que c'est
rien non c'est pas rien parce que ça
traduit un certain malaise j'ai beaucoup
de ses collègues une contestation qui
est autre que scientifique je suis
entièrement d'accord deuxièmement les
antivacs à l'hôpital ne devraient pas
exister ou chez les soignants ça ne
devrait pas exister et d'ailleurs il y a
des obligations il y a des obligations
vaccinales un soignant et vacciné qu'on
ne l'hépatite B et quand les autres
obligations et et troisièmement encore
une fois excusez-moi mais pour ou contre
l'obligation vaccinale sur ce rappel là
parce que c'est une vraie question qu'il
faut poser sur des gens qui sont allés
chercher
leur références sur les sites
complotistes plus que dans les avis de
la HAS ou de l'Académie de médecine
dans le métier du soin c'est un vrai
souci la cohérence dans l'équipe de
soins c'est un vrai souci d'avoir c'est
intéressant dans une enquête les Anglais
ont fait cette enquête là ils ont posé
la question aux soignants anglais est-ce
que vous êtes pour ou contre
l'obligation vaccinale 1 sur 6 et pour
l'obligation là on est sur la
réintégration
le climat social dans dans les services
Mathieu on va continuer de de creuser un
peu la question des conséquences
politiques finalement de de cette
épidémie puisque la gestion de la crise
covid elle fait l'enquête elle fait
l'objet pardon d'une enquête de la Cour
de Justice de la République en en est où
la France est le seul pays au monde à
attaqué ses dirigeants pour la gestion
de la crise coïti vous avez entendu
cette petite phrase elle a été martelée
notamment par l'ancienne ministre de la
Santé Agnès Buzyn qui n'a pas vraiment
tort sur le coup faut le dire même si
des enquêtes avaient été annoncées au
Brésil par exemple contre Jr bolsonaro
pour sa gestion de de l'épidémie de
covid ou même si en Italie par exemple
dès 2020 l'ancien Premier ministre yu-gp
compter avait été entendu par par à
Bergame par le parquet de Bergame la
France est quand même en effet le seul
pays au monde où une enquête d'une telle
a été lancé alors les juges de la Cour
de justice ils tentent de déterminer si
les membres du gouvernement de l'époque
ont une responsabilité dans la
propagation de l'épidémie de covid
notamment lors de la première vague
essentiellement en 2020 à ce jour seul
Agnès Buzy donc l'ancienne ministre de
la Santé a fait l'objet d'une mise en
examen pour mise en danger de la vidéo
truie et elle est placée sous statut de
témoin assisté pour abstention
volontaire de combattre un sinistre
Edouard Philippe lui qui était en
premier ministre à l'époque a échappé la
mise en examen pour les deux mêmes
motifs mais il a été placé sous le
statut de témoin Cissé contre un ancien
ministre de la Santé l'autre Olivier
Véran qui avait succédé au pied levé
vous souvenez à celle-ci avait décidé de
tenter les municipales à Paris et ben il
est aussi visé par l'enquête mais n'a
pas encore été entendue par les juges de
la CGR comment peut-on expliquer cette
spécificité française alors c'est
d'abord la marque de l'indépendance des
pouvoirs je vais dire et à ce titre il
faut sans doute sans féliciter parce que
contrairement aux âneries que racontent
les complotistes veulent la justice peut
faire son travail pour le reste c'est
poursuite s'explique on est à mes yeux
par de bonnes et de mauvaises raisons
les bonnes c'est évidemment essayer de
comprendre comment les autorités ont
géré la crise covid c'est à dire ce qui
était fait ce qui n'a pas été fait en
matière de prévention on parlait des
masques en matière de mesure sanitaires
les couvre-feu le confinement en matière
de soins aussi en tout cas de est-ce que
pourquoi les hôpitaux ont-ils été à ce
point débordé tout ça ce sont des
questions légitimes pour tirer les
leçons et qui ont été d'une certaine
manière déjà posée par les commissions
d'enquête parlementaires par le travail
journalistique donc une partie de ces
questions là ont déjà été posées et on a
connu parfois donc les bonnes raisons
les mauvaises raisons à mes yeux c'est
de pouvoir chercher à tout prix un
coupable ou un bouc émissaire pour un
fléau qui est quand même s'est abattu à
l'échelle planétaire ici en France mais
aussi partout ailleurs faut le rappeler
la France n'était pas prête certes mais
quel pays il était la France attardée à
prendre des mesures la mesure de la
pandémie elle a peut-être même
sous-estimé oui encore mais la vérité où
je vais dire qu'elle n'est pas la seule
à avoir tâtonné à cette laisser déborder
par l'ampleur de cette pandémie qui
était inédite il faut quand même le
rappeler souvenez-vous au Royaume-Uni
les premières mesures qui ont été prises
c'était plutôt de laisser circuler le
virus d'autres pays ils l'ont tenté
aussi le coït en fait le problème c'est
que c'est enfin le problème c'est
surtout que c'est une tragédie qui a
fait près de 160000 morts en France
causant autant de drames pour toutes les
familles pour tous les proches qui ont
perdu quelqu'un dans cette dans cette
tragédie on parle je parle même pas des
covidons et encore des gens qui sont
marqués dans leur chair dans leur esprit
et toutes les conséquences
psychologiques mais et même si c'est
inaudible pour les victimes donc je mets
beaucoup de guillemets la France n'a pas
forcément fait moins bien que les autres
pays
notamment en termes de mortalité elle a
pas fait mieux elle n'a pas forcément
fait moins bien une enquête publiée par
la revue Nature human behavior sur la
mortalité le mois dernier
sur l'expérience de vie voilà et ben
elle montre que la France compte parmi
les pays qui ont le mieux résisté la
perte d'espérance de vie et a été plus
faible qu'ailleurs et a été voilà en
regain et on a retrouvé notre niveau de
2019 donc je suffit pas que c'est
parfait du tout il faut bien que tout le
monde m'entende la France a pas
forcément fait moins bien est-ce que ça
veut dire que les dirigeants de l'époque
l'ont de compte à rendre la personne non
bien sûr mais ce qu'il faut en faire
pour autant des suspects découpables ou
des complices sans doute non plus eux se
défendre en disant qu'ils se font fait
ce qu'ils ont ce qu'ils ont pu l'opinion
une partie de l'opinion les condamne
déjà en disant qu'ils auraient dû faire
autre chose ou qu'ils n'ont pas fait ce
qu'ils auraient dû la justice tranchera
pour savoir s'il y a eu des fautes des
erreurs des négligences je me rappelle
quand même comme politique même les
mauvais choix politiques sera jugent
généralement rarement au tribunal mais
plutôt dans les urnes effectivement
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez Christine
Rosie ou c'est abusif cette cette
procédure judiciaire on est dans on est
dans dans une justice qui fonctionne la
Cour de justice la République les
ministres peuvent être mis en cause il y
a pas de souci là-dessus mais quand vous
faites le bilan vous je me prononcerai
pas sur le cas d'Agnès buza c'est c'est
trop personnel mais par contre sur le
fait que le bilan de la France est le
travail des Hospitaliers a été
remarquable et c'est vrai que
le fait que cette espérance de vie
finalement
on est vraiment dans dans la situation
les meilleurs pays c'est un résultat
remarquable il faut vraiment le dire et
d'autant que cette espérance de vie
remonte et de nouveau positif ça veut
bien dire que on a un système de santé
qu'il faut protéger parce que il marche
bien et il faut vraiment s'en occuper
c'est vraiment ça pour moi le message
alors maintenant le côté juridique bon
ben c'est évident qu'il n'y avait plus
de masque c'est évident que les alertes
avaient été donnés en juillet 2019 c'est
évident que on connaît tout ça on
connaît les noms de toutes les lettres
qui ont circulées en disant alerte ils
sont périmés et que et que rien n'a
bougé il y a quand même il y a quand
même des choses
Didier au sein le rappel combien lui il
avait fait les stocks au moment où il
était directeur de la DGS et tout mais à
ce moment là voilà on n'était pas dans
le même état d'esprit donc il y a quand
même eu des choses qui sont passées qui
peuvent pas être totalement ignorés
merci beaucoup merci à tous je vais
citer votre livre Gérald kirzak votre
santé dans le monde d'après préparer la
aujourd'hui c'est publié aux éditions du
Rocher et puis moi je vais terminer en
disant vaccinez-vous et portez le masque
dans les transports c'est mon opinion
mais je termine comme ça c'est mon
pouvoir de présentateur de l'émission
d'avoir la conclusion merci encore à